- All right, everybody
focus up, look.
This party tonight
could be a model
for the way that the
world should work.
And I just wanna say,
I'm totally stoked to the
max about it, all right?
You guys feeling good?
- Yeah.
- Hell yeah.
- Dennis, what are
you shooting video?
- [Dennis] Yeah man.
- All right, well,
be careful with that.
I might run for office someday.
(all laugh)
Now, trust me, I think
that this party can be
the most inspirational party
this campus has ever seen.
Is that coming to me?
Let me just grab that.
Some righteous bud,
some righteous bud
we got going on there.
We need some bodacious
jock babes coming in.
- [Guy] Yeah.
- We need some hot
ass punk rock babes.
- Yeah.
- Woo.
- I don't care where
they come from.
The most important thing,
it's imperative that we have
a diversity in the
pussy department.
Intercepted, don't
sleep on Barry O.
Don't ever sleep on Barry O.
Ooh, that is some major doobage.
(people chat)
- Hey.
- Apartheid, that's
totally gnarly.
It's a gnarly institution.
Where is he?
Dennis, Dennis, come over here.
Get this, get this.
Okay, we gotta have
a system in place
to get everybody
weed, all right?
So just watch this.
This is how you're
gonna do it, all right.
This, this...
I'm really (bleep) frosty
right now, by the way.
This is your
constitution, all right?
It's just a piece of paper.
We gotta keep its integrity,
'cause it's gonna hold
everything together.
This right here, this is us.
This is the American people.
We're special, we're magic.
Oh, yeah, get all of it here.
All right, the most
important thing
is that we don't
get too far apart.
Me and you, we gotta be close.
That's that's the magic
of America, is love.
Otherwise, we're gonna
get air bubbles in there.
It's gonna start
canoeing and everything.
We don't want that.
All right, you get that?
All right look, I'm way ahead
of you, but I'm already done.
Boom fireworks, 4th of July.
That's for you.
We want like 10 of these.
Oh my God, I'm so
(bleep) blazed. (laughs)
I'm so (bleep) high.
Oh (bleep) what was I saying?